[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
politique à table sur LCP l'émission on
parle agriculture alimentation cuisine
écologie et un peu politique autour d'un
plat d'un dessert et d'un invité et
cette semaine nous recevons un amoureux
de la bonne chère le critique culinaire
François Régis Gaudry bonjour bonjour et
bienvenue merci d'être avec nous et avec
moi pour présenter cette émission
Jean-Pierre Montanet bonjour Jean-Pierre
bonjour Brigitte bonjour François
Régis Gaudry vous êtes journaliste
auteur et critique gastronomique après
des études à principaux pour assurer vos
parents vous contribuez au Fooding
chroniquer sur la consommation à Europe
1 et tenez la chronique restaurant de
L'Express on fait pas tous les jours un
métier facile désormais on peut vous
voir dans la première partie de Top Chef
sur M6 sur Paris Première dans
l'émission très très bon et vous
entendre tous les dimanches sur France
Inter dans on va déguster un titre que
vous avez décliné comme une collection
on va déguster la France on va déguster
l'Italie et votre tout dernier ouvrage
on va déguster Paris un indice pour le
menu du jour Jean-Paul exactement avec
le cresson qui est à l'honneur page 32
dans ce livre et dans votre menu avec
une soupe toute verte et en dessert un
Paris-Brest dans le dessous des plats le
succès des bouillons c'est vieux
restaurants parisiens au tarif
attractives retrouvent la cote et
cartonne même chez les jeunes dans les
pieds dans le plat faut-il se fier à ses
avis de consommateurs qui en sens ou
dézingue les restaurants enquêtes à
suivre allez on passe à table tout de
suite cuisine et confidence
à François Régis Gaudry cette soupe de
cresson trop verte pour être honnête et
amer à vous faire grimacer vous l'auriez
volontiers échanger pendant votre
enfance contre les pires frites surgelés
mais n'oublions pas Brigitte que cette
soupe était amoureusement préparée par
votre maman en attente de compliments en
vain mange ta soupe tonnelle à daronne
sinon tu vas déguster et voilà tout est
parti de là bingo vous avez zappé le
sens populaire de la formule pour garder
son sens premier on va se régaler pour
faire cette émission de cuisine culte on
va déguster et part rancunier le
François Régis avec l'âge votre palais
s'est bonifié et voilà que cette année
soupe est devenue un must si t'es même
sur les ondes sous la tendre appellation
le velouté de cresson de ma mère et son
topping poivrée 30 ans plus tard donc
tout pour la daronne gros respect et
l'autre panthéon des grands chefs et la
soupe de cresson jadis méprisé votre
nouveau phare c'est pas vrai ça bah
c'est bien résumé Jean-Pierre en effet
c'était une soupe au départ que j'ai eu
un peu de mal à manger puis vous
connaissez le syndrome de Stockholm à un
moment donné on est pris en otage par un
plat qu'on n'aime pas forcément et puis
on finit à force de à force de le
déguster à force de le voir sur la table
on finit par par l'apprécier en réalité
je l'ai apprécié assez rapidement parce
que j'aime beaucoup dans cette soupe
d'abord sa texture un peu glissante ça
c'est apporté par le cresson qui a
justement cette texture un peu fondante
que j'aime bien j'en aime la couleur
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que ma mère je
lui disais tiens encore une soupe verte
je sais pas 7 8 ans ce qui était le
cresson et puis j'aime aussi ce
contraste un peu sm entre la caresse et
la classe
dans le caisson vous avez la petite
caresse de la suabilité du cresson parce
qu'il faut quand même se démission de
cuisine François Régis
je me souviens même que le cresson c'est
un cousin du chou donc il y a il y a sa
part de sucre et en même temps
il y a de la caresse et il y a
effectivement cette petite claque un peu
poivrée que j'apprécie particulièrement
on va voir s'il y a cette petite claque
cette soupe au cresson alors je voudrais
pas vous dire si elle ressemble à celle
de votre maman bien sûr il doit être
bien au-delà de
[Musique]
ce que j'apprécie en plus c'est qu'elle
est liée ça veut dire qu'elle a
certainement été préparée avec des
pommes de terre oui ça permet de donner
un peu donc exactement celle de ma mère
était peut-être un peu plus liquide un
peu plus cressonné entre guillemets mais
là j'apprécie particulièrement la
texture on a quand même la trame très
chlorophylle du cresson que j'aime
beaucoup
savoir sur le sur le cresson Jean-Pierre
éclairer nous un petit peu justement
parce que Fred montre cresson c'est pas
bien d'où ça vient alors il y a deux
cressons il y a d'abord le cresson de
fontaine riche en vitamines qui est en
minéraux c'est une plante alors
semi-aquatique qui pousse donc dans des
bassins d'eau pure vraiment de l'eau
pure pour faire un bon caisson mode de
production un peu particulier vous
l'imaginez il faut des bassins qui
explique la rareté de secret sont il
existe aussi un cresson de terre appelé
l'alien noix il est plus piquant pour
rejoindre ce que vous disiez Brigitte et
lui il peut pousser dans un potager
toute l'année et chez vous il y a pas de
problème à l'origine il était cueilli à
l'état sauvage puis création a été
cultivé en France à partir du 19e siècle
pour ses vertus culinaires aussi
médicinales il fait du bien pour la
santé et les premières cressonnières qui
leur apparition dans l'Oise à son lit et
à Chantilly où il y avait des grands
bassins d'eau enfin si on consomme
souvent cru en salade le cresson aux
feuilles très délicates et à tomber
aussi cuit juste poêlé mixer sous forme
de soupe avec éventuellement des pommes
de terre des échalotes de la crème puis
après on peut rajouter ce qu'on veut
madame Gaudry fait un gros topping ouais
avec des graines de courge avec parfois
même un petit peu pour ajouter encore de
la moutarde un petit condiment au
raifort mais c'est vrai que le cresson
je l'aime à la fois cuit je l'aime aussi
cru en salade comme le rappeler
Jean-Pierre c'est un très bon légume que
l'on peut faire sauter comme ça avec une
couche d'oeil du cresson
elle a un peu disparu elle s'est fait un
peu oublié alors qu'elle était légumes
oui voilà elle était en fait extrêmement
populaire à la fin du 19e tout le
courant du 20e siècle c'était même par
excellence le légume
de toutes les saisons que l'on trouvait
aux Halles au cœur de Paris on faisait
d'ailleurs une soupe
du cresson on trouve toute l'année parce
qu'en fait comme la rappeler Jean-Pierre
c'est une plante qui est semi-aquatique
on dit que elle pousse les pieds dans
l'eau et la tête au soleil et c'est vrai
que on la ramasse dans des cressonnières
ce sont vraiment des bassins alimentés
par des sources d'eau ou par des
rivières il faut qu'il y ait de la
pureté il faut vraiment que l'eau soit
et elle est récoltée vraiment toute
l'année par des gens dont c'est le
métier beaucoup dans l'Essonne
d'ailleurs puisque
arrêtez-moi si je me trompe le cresson
Fontaine il est toute l'année parce que
j'ai l'impression que le création de
Fontaine n'était pas toute l'année mais
ce qui permettait d'avoir du création
toute l'année c'est parce qu'elle crée
son potager je peux me tromper mais en
fait
quand il fait froid que il arrive pas à
pousser mais en réalité moi je suis allé
faire des reportages en janvier même au
printemps en l'été le cresson de
fontaine est quand même là la major
partie de l'année ouais est-ce que vous
avez perpétué cette tradition du coup
familiale est-ce que vous vous
en faites chez vous est-ce que vous
aimez cuisiner déjà parce que quand on
est critiqué culinaire on aime déguster
est-ce qu'on aime aussi mettre à la pâte
vous avez raison de poser la question
parce que quand on est journaliste
gastronomique on cuisine pas forcément
d'ailleurs moi ces gens-là je les
appelle les gastronomes passifs ça veut
pas dire que ils ont pas un palais
évidemment pour découvrir et appréhender
la cuisine des autres mais moi j'ai
toujours eu cette curiosité d'essayer de
comprendre techniquement comment se
décliner un plat que je déguster au
restaurant j'ai souvent essayé de
reproduire d'ailleurs des recettes de
chef lorsque j'ai un petit coup de
foudre pour un plat en général j'appelle
le chef j'essaie de lui stocker la
recette ou un truc pour demain pour
reproduire ou c'est la prolongation de
votre métier finalement c'est une
curiosité qui est devenue un véritable
plaisir et qui est aussi une nécessité
parce que je suis père de famille je
nourris ma famille
s'il y a bien un truc que j'ai à peu
près réussi pas tout mais avec mes
enfants c'est de leur comment dire de
leur avoir offert ouvert leur chakra
culinaire des choses si on est
relativement compliqué il y a bien
entendu en plus toutes ces phases de
phobie alimentaire etc mais aujourd'hui
elles sont ados et on peut considérer
que globalement elles sont ouvertes à
tout y compris à ce cresson et à cette
soupe que j'ai hérité de ma mère il y a
des a priori des préjugés aussi des
enfants il faut les faire aller au-delà
des préjugés sur des goûts des saveurs
des textures et pour la petite histoire
moi c'est parce que quand j'ai vu que
vous êtes une soupe de création j'en ai
fait une mardi à la maison et j'ai
découvert cette soupe de cresson j'en
avais jamais fait elle était aussi bonne
que celle que vous l'aviez réussi
cuisiner qu'est-ce que vous pourriez
nous préparer c'est quoi vos plat
fétiches vos spécialités à vous je fais
vraiment une cuisine assez simple une
cuisine du quotidien une cuisine qui
peut à la fois s'inspirer du répertoire
populaire et bourgeois que ma mère
cuisinait des recettes corses également
car j'ai des origines du côté de la
Corse avec exactement qui cuisinait
super bien à Bastia et là j'ai hérité
effectivement de ces courgettes farcies
au brocciu vous savez ce fameux
que l'on trouve d'ailleurs en ce moment
on est en pleine saison et là je me
régale à l'envie avec ces recettes là et
puis mon répertoire peu à peu c'est
alimenté c'est nourri de toutes les
recettes que j'ai découvertes y compris
dans des petits bruits asiatiques
traditionnelle française
voilà je fais
je discute un jour avec Jean-Pierre
montaney qui pratique un excellent porc
au caramel je dis pas ça parce qu'il est
là il était remarquable et je me suis
permis de le faire à son tour je lui ai
estorqué la recette il me la balançait
dans exactement
un must que j'ai même partagé avec mes
auditeurs de France Inter alors vous
avez goûté toutes les cuisines du monde
vous avez tout essayé non il y a quelque
chose encore qui reste un mystère pour
vous véritablement une 420 et c'est ça
qui fait d'ailleurs tout l'intérêt de
mon métier c'est qu'on sent lasse pas
parce que
[Musique]
quand on aimerait bien de Montaigne
c'est que je finis par me dire et plus
le temps avant je finis par me dire que
tout ce que je sais en matière de
cuisine c'est qu'en fait je ne sais rien
quoi c'est-à-dire que évidemment mon
bagage de connaissances c'est nourri au
fil des années à largement est devenu
même un peu obèse parce que je connais
pas mal de choses mais il y a des pays
dans lesquels je n'ai pas voyagé j'ai
des grosses statuts qu'une culinaires je
vous donne un exemple hier j'ai testé
pour mon émission très très bon avec ma
petite caméra un restaurant remarquable
d'ailleurs un petit mexicain pas très
cher avec une jouer la 22 euros en
treplay du 10ème arrondissement ça
s'appelle comer bon toute une leçon
voilà manger en espagnol toute une leçon
de cuisine non pas sur le tacos qui est
un peu justement le cliché mexicain mais
sur une cuisine familiale que je ne
connaissais pas une cuisine mexicaine je
l'ai voyagé qu'une seule fois au Mexique
et je n'ai qu'une seule envie c'est d'y
retourner parce qu'on sait que le
Mexique est un continent culinaire
incroyable qui a d'ailleurs été classé
au patrimoine immatériel de l'Unesco
voilà il faut effectivement
connaître un peu les bons restaurants
du Pérou aussi il y a les 20 ans au
Pérou on mange mal et maintenant les
chefs péruviens sont demandés par toutes
les rentables exactement vous ne pouvez
pas ingurgiter avaler j'aime un truc
n'aimais pas pouvoir vous dire oui mais
la réalité c'est que je suis un omnivore
complet dans le sens où il y a rien qui
m'a rebuté si il y a une chose que je
n'ai jamais mangé j'ai fait un voyage
les méduses en Chine alors les méduses
non j'en ai mangé et d'ailleurs j'ai
trouvé ça très intéressant en revanche
je me suis arrêté devant une assiette de
chiens après une visite au marché de
canton là effectivement je me suis
attendu d'en manger mais j'ai même mangé
de la chauve-souris aux Seychelles une
chauve-souris je tiens à le préciser qui
n'était pas du tout en voie de
disparition d'ailleurs parce que je suis
évidemment très soucieux de ce qui se
passe dans mon assiette en terme de de
de ressources et de vertus mais il est
vrai que j'ai vraiment essayé des
sensations très différentes pour vous
c'est quoi le must de la cuisine la
meilleure cuisine du monde c'est ça
vient d'où c'est compliqué à dire parce
que véritablement je pense que tout
répertoire à son intérêt je suis très
porté sur la France évidemment puisque
c'est mon pays celui que je le connais
que je le connais peut-être avec le plus
de de de familiarité de proximité après
j'ai une énorme passion pour ce qui se
passe de l'autre côté des Alpes en
Italie et j'ai fait énormément de
voyages du côté de la botte parce que je
suis fasciné par ce répertoire qui
justement contrairement à celui de la
France n'est pas un rasoir élitiste
sophistiqué mais qui est resté en fait
sur le le niveau d'une coaching à pomera
c'est-à-dire une cuisine familial et
accessible et en général assez romaine
exactement pour après je suis évidemment
fasciné pour y avoir fait une dizaine de
voyages par le Japon et sa cuisine d'une
d'une diversité et d'une à la fois d'une
d'une complexité incroyable et la
cuisine de demain ce serait quoi pour
vous qui avez vu cette cuisine évolué au
fil des des ans qu'est-ce qui nous
attend demain ce sont les insectes dont
on parle régulièrement c'est au moins de
viande c'est quoi
une apparition très remarquée dans les
prochaines années mais pas uniquement
sous la forme du criquet qu'on va avoir
sur un tamalès ou un tacos ça va être
plutôt effectivement des farines de
verre de farine justement qui vont
apporter une part de protéines animales
pour contrebalancer justement les autres
protéines dont on va devoir diminuer la
production et la consommation bah
clairement notre cuisine à l'échelle de
20 30 ans sera très clairement moins
carnet
les protéines animales auront tendance à
s'effacer c'est une bonne chose mais je
pense que c'est aussi l'occasion de
remettre au goût du jour bah des
végétaux très porteurs de protéines
comme par exemple les fameuses
légumineuses on sait que les protéines
comme celle du pois chiche des lentilles
des haricots secs sont de formidable
nutriments pour notre organisme mais
c'est contraintes n'est pas peur qu'on
aille vers des années moins gourmandes
parce que là vous ne faites pas rêver
avec les farines d'insectes on parle de
la viande de laboratoire avec des
cellules souches soit c'est ce que
après effectivement il faut voir avec le
contexte climato est-ce que vous n'avez
pas peur que en termes de gourmandise et
de plaisir on n'a pas atteint un pic et
on
aurait tendance à penser qu'on irausé le
plaisir ailleurs quand je vous parlais
de la cuisine italienne elle est
justement assez peu alors attention il y
a des grands plats italiens à base de
viande de poisson évidemment mais quand
vous prenez la cuisine du Sud notamment
celle de Basilica dépouille de Sicile et
de Calabre exactement vous vous rendez
compte que la la portion de protéines
animales est vraiment réduite de façon
considérable quand vous allez aller tuer
dans les Pouilles et que vous mangez par
exemple tria etcheci c'est ces fameux
plates pattes avec des pois chiches bah
là on a un plat complet puisqu'on a on
additionne céréales plus légumineuses ce
sont des protéines complètes le plat est
donc parfaitement équilibré et là on
prend un plaisir fou avec des bonnes
blanquette alors la banque la blanquette
on continuera évidemment à la manger et
puis je compte on continuera à être
omnivore me semble-t-il même si je pense
que la part des mangeurs végétariens et
végétaliens va augmenter au fil des
années toutefois je pense que ce sera
l'occasion de se faire une vraie fête
lorsqu'on aura l'occasion de manger de
la viande à condition qu'elle soit
évidemment issues d'élevage respectueux
de l'environnement respectueux de la
santé des des producteurs respectueux
aussi bien sûr du bien-être animal alors
quand on déguste on déguste aussi du vin
en général alors là c'est un code du
Rhône que vous avez choisi donc c'est un
vin rouge on le voit de Montbrison sur
l'Est et de Valréas avec 70% de grenades
20% de cirer 10% de sans eau élevé en
cuve j'ai fait quelques recherches
pourquoi ce vin et est-ce qu'il va bien
finalement avec la soupe de cresson il
s'accorde assez bien avec la soupe de
cresson mais ce que j'aime bien
justement dans ce vin c'est que c'est un
vin tout à fait polyvalent c'est un
Vincent prétention d'ailleurs écoute
moins de 10 € c'est un soir voilà
exactement un vin qui explose de fruits
avec une macération carbonique qui va
justement flatter les arômes de ces
trois cépages qui font l'assemblage de
ce vin de la Drôme c'est Maxime Laurent
qui le signe qui est le fils d'une
vigneronne qui a été assez emblématique
dans l'univers nature et qui s'appelle
Michel Aubéry le domaine de Grammont et
le fils a repris justement ce domaine
alors il fait des cuvées très évolué
comme la fameuse cuvée de mémé à base de
grenache plus que centenaire mais il
fait par ailleurs ce que j'appellerais
cette cuvette copains ce premier vin de
soif qui est tout à fait gourmand pas
très cher d'un bon rapport qualité-prix
adapté à cette soupe de cresson sans
aucune hésitation et je l'aime tout
simplement pour son côté simple et
flatteur vous êtes très très fort on va
voir si vous êtes incollables c'est le
quiz
alors à part vous guide bien sûr le
guide Michelin est sans doute votre
Bible mais seriez-vous nous dire
pourquoi à partir de 1920 ce guide
gratuit cette petite livre rouge devient
payant a pour le doter d'une couverture
cartonnée plus résistante et plus chic B
pour amortir la hausse du prix des
pneumatiques dues à la flambiste
historique des cours du caoutchouc c'est
parce que Michelin était déçu de voir
son guide gratuit utilisé pour caler les
pieds d'une table je vais un de ces
distributeurs dès enfin pour mettre fin
aux critiques de la presse qui affirmait
que ce livre rouge était financé par les
restaurants cité dans le guide
[Rires]
je sais que le guide Michelin partir des
années 30 a commencé à remettre des
étoiles est-ce que c'est pour
alors 1920 il bien payant et
effectivement 1930 il commence à mettre
des étoiles alors qu'avant il était
juste un guide de voyage le B c'est
parce qu'il
pour amortir la hausse des prix des
pneumatiques Michelin faisait des pneus
manufacturiers ça me semblera assez
crédible comme hypothèse je dirais B
alors non ça c'est né dans mon
imagination pas mal et c'était non
c'était tout simplement parce que un
jour un type de Michelin a vu chez un
distributeur un guide sous une table
pour la tenir alors qu'elle était
bancale ça l'a rendu dingue il s'est dit
si elle est payante s'il est payante il
le fera il l'utilisera plus de cette
façon cette anecdote m'a été totalement
échappée bravo vous allez pouvoir vous
rattraper parce que vous êtes né dans
les faubourg de la capitale de la
gastronomie Lyon alors sauriez-vous nous
dire pourquoi cette spécialité le gras
double pané s'appelle le tablier de
sapeur
a en référence au charcutier tripier
lyonnais Marcel sapeur inventeur de
cette recette en 1910 en référence B au
maréchal de Castellane ancien sapeur du
génie dont le tablier ressemblait
étrangement au plan c'est parce que la
consommation sans modération de ce plat
très gras avait tendance à donner du
ventre et qu'il fallait camoufler
derrière un tablier ça c'est un truc que
vous allez bien
parce que les sapeurs-pompiers des de
Lyon dans les années 20 avait l'habitude
d'en déguster pour ce requinquer après
de dures interventions là j'ai ma petite
idée je crois savoir que c'est la
réponse B
maréchal de Castel est aussi le
gouverneur militaire de Lyon
ça ressemble à un tablier de pompier en
caoutchouc ou en toile de cuir ceci
étant qu'elle régale je sais pas si vous
avez eu l'occasion de vous attabler dans
un bouchon lyonnais mais quand vous
accompagnez ça d'une sauce tartare alors
évidemment faut pas faire attention à
ces calories c'est pas vraiment un plat
de janvier mais c'est un régal cholesté
le cholestérol on prend un petit coup
alors ça je l'ai pas vu dans votre livre
on va déguster Paris c'est votre
actualité un livre auquel vous avez
contribué Jean-Pierre fouetto sur les
recettes thaï j'ai été traquée les
meilleurs resto taille de Paris et vous
aviez une question à poser à François
Régis Gaudry sur ce livre oui vous
l'appelez
guide alors ça veut dire quoi parce
qu'on y parle pas que de la sienne c'est
un peu antinomique alors soit c'est un
guide et qui est un peu éternel soit
sinon qui est un peu éphémère soit une
encyclopédique et éternelle c'est un
produit hybride
c'est-à-dire qu'on a on n'a jamais
vraiment réussi à qualifier même les
livres précédents qui étaient sur le
même principe
encyclopédie on a inventé ce n'est
logisme pour cette occasion c'est moitié
encyclopédie
[Musique]
moitié guide sachant que le guide on est
déjà en train de le réactualiser pour
l'année prochaine donc l'idée évidemment
c'est de le rendre pérenne et de faire
en sorte qu'ils suivent l'actualité de
la scène gastronomique parisienne mais
il est vrai que on voulait en faire à la
fois un livre de sa voix avec tout ce
qui concerne finalement le patrimoine
immense et parfois méconnu d'être
d'ailleurs qui est le la cuisine et la
gastronomie parisienne et en même temps
on ne se voyait pas faire un livre sur
la cuisine parisienne sans y ajouter les
grandes adresses de commerce de bouche
il y a des recettes il y a des produits
et on trouve un livre de cuisine mais ça
nous paraît être plus qu'un livre de
cuisine il y a quand même une centaine
de recettes et de et notamment de
recettes parisiennes avec bien
évidemment là où le rayon parisien c'est
tout le répertoire sucré puisque Paris a
quand même enfanté de très nombreuses
recettes qui sont désormais connues dans
le monde entier comme le macaron
parisien ou le flan comme vous le disiez
mais il est vrai qu'on voulait aussi y
ajouter toutes les adresses de
restaurants qu'on aime bien notre force
de frappe entre guillemets avec mon
petit collectif c'est que l'on écume
Paris à longueur de semaine et qu'on
connaît aussi des gens très bien et très
connaisseurs comme un certain Montana
qui est spécialiste de la cuisine
asiatique et qui nous a effectivement
rencardés sur tous les restaurants en
taille de Paris donc c'est vrai qu'on a
comme ça accumulé un certain nombre
d'expertises en fonction du goût et des
connaissances de des contributeurs qu'on
a choisi et c'est comme ça qu'on est
arrivé à adresser un panorama assez
large de la scène gastronomique
on n'est pas beaucoup de ouais on n'est
pas on a essayé en tout cas d'approcher
le d'approcher le le livre le plus
complet possible et le prochain il sera
sur quoi parce qu'on a vu les délire on
a vu Paris je le sais pas encore c'est
vrai que je vous disais que j'adorais le
Japon mais il faudrait vraiment s'y
installer parce que j'ai quand même
l'humilité de me dire que pour le Japon
il faut vraiment s'y concentrer pendant
si consacrer pendant des années après je
suis à côté sur par mes origines et puis
par par mes voyages très portés sur la
Méditerranée mais très sincèrement à ce
stade j'en sais pas tellement plus sur
prise sur la table
autour des repas sont donc assez
fréquentes et on passe donc à la brève
de comptoir
alors on vous a demandé de réfléchir
sans régisse Gaudry a une anecdote
autour d'un repas et pourquoi pas en
politique si vous en aviez une est-ce
que vous avez
un souvenir à nous raconter oui qui date
il y a quelques mois ça s'est passé chez
Yves camp deborde je sais pas si vous
connaissez le chef qu'on considère
souvent d'ailleurs comme le papa de la
bistronomie cette petite cuisine cette
grande cuisine de petits bistrot qu'il a
un peu mis au point dans les années 90
et est fait du confinement il condeborde
a décidé de baisser le rideau en fait et
d'aller s'installer dans le Sud alors
qu'il avait quand même derrière lui une
quarantaine d'années de carrière il
avait une place à Saint-Germain
exactement et il m'envoie un sms pour me
dire je fais plusieurs petits dîner en
tout petit comité ça me ferait très
plaisir que tu y participes parce que je
fais mes adieux à la scène parisienne et
je souhaiterais avant de partir
remercier tous ceux qui ont contribué à
ma carrière il est vrai que c'est un
chef que je connais bien et je débarque
dans cette petite salle
avec 8 invités et je me retrouve en face
de François Hollande et Julie Gayet et
j'ai eu l'occasion de constater que
l'ancien président avait effectivement
un sacré coup de fourchette on a eu
un très très beau pâté en croûte dont le
l'ancien président a repris deux belles
tranches on a ensuite eu une salade une
très belle Macédoine avec avec yomar et
on a fini avec un turbo au four qui
était vraiment remarquable et puis bien
entendu plateau de fromage et chariots
de dessert et c'est là où vous rendez
compte que vous avez en face de vous
d'abord quelqu'un de d'extrêmement
sympathique de très blagueurs avec
beaucoup d'humour mais qui en même temps
a une sacrée connaissance de ce qu'il a
dans son assiette voilà il est très
préoccupé par la chose mais pas
uniquement pour le plaisir de bafray de
se nourrir il est aussi par par choix de
vie pas esthétique et il est voilà donc
c'est c'est comme ça que ça m'a assez
amusé en fait de vérifier et puisque
j'en avais entendu parler à plusieurs
reprises
qu'il avait non seulement un bon coup de
fourchette mais un goût très sûr dans la
gastronomie et j'ai eu l'occasion de
vérifier que c'était vrai
en 1860 qui retrouve leur succès d'antan
alors pourquoi c'est le dessous des
plats
et oui ils étaient tombés en 18d mais
les bouillons reviennent au goût du jour
ses ancêtres des brasseries proposent un
service simple efficace dans une
ambiance conviviale au milieu d'un décor
Art Nouveau les prix sont aussi très
attractifs si bien que les clients y
retournent en nombre un succès qui ne se
dément pas comme un pu le constater
Stéphanie Despierre et janutin au
bouillon République à Paris
ce n'est pas une file d'attente pour un
spectacle ni pour l'ouverture de la
dernière boutique à la mode mais pour
entrer au bouillon République un
restaurant de cuisine française
traditionnelle il y a quelques touristes
mais surtout des dizaines d'habitants
n'a plus de secret le gratin de courge
au bleu d'Auvergne et aux noix c'est
délicieux ou les ravioles de Royan et
font des poireaux mais le parmentier de
cochon a l'air dingue donc on va faire
un petit mouette dont les assiettes les
classiques français poulet frites
j'arrête porc boeuf bourguignon ou
encore terrine de campagne et poireaux
vinaigrette sauce ravigote c'est de la
cuisine de grand-mère c'est très
populaire
des plats en sauce surtout voilà c'est
très simple mais très bon et en grande
quantité les poireaux vinaigrette le
chef et ses équipes en prépare 600
portions par semaine pour les œufs
mayonnaise c'est 6000 et ils écoutent
deux tonnes et demi de pommes de terre
pour les frites et les purées
les recettes sont connues de tous mais
la fabrication à grande échelle reste
confidentielle nous ne sommes pas
autorisés à filmer la cuisine ici on
sert 1500 repas quotidiens de midi à
minuit 7 jours sur 7 table 40 j'ai tout
sauf le saumon je reviens à la récupérer
il y a 70 personnes en cuisine une
quarantaine en salle alors
l'organisation et millimétré je contrôle
tous les plateaux tout ce qui sort de la
cuisine et surtout pour les erreurs quel
serveur s'il te plaît le serveur
voilà 38 à 97 donc tu as un gratin de
courge une betterave et une cuisse de
poulet
et là ils ont leur plateau je vois pas
mais je leur annonce justement et comme
ça il vérifie ça leur évite de faire des
allers-retours
inutilement ce restaurant ouvert en 2021
et le deuxième bouillon lancé par les
frères Moussier un duo qui a remis à la
mode ce vieux concept parisien le
bouillon existait vraiment on va dire au
début du 20e siècle on avait près de 250
boulons un coup sur Paris et en effet
après-guerre 14-18 il y a eu on va dire
en plein effondrement de des bouillons
avec le système des brasseries des
rondelles
on est parti dans constat simple sur sur
l'offre du marché en ces années 2010
c'est que il manquait vraiment un côté
accessible pour pour les clients avec un
bon rapport qualité prix les tarifs
défis toutes concurrence très clairement
entrée plat dessert pour moins de 30
euros dans une brasserie classique c'est
difficile c'est traditionnel on connaît
les plats qu'on aille dans un bouillon
dans un autre on retrouve à peu près les
mêmes plats donc on a pas de surprise ni
en qualité ni en prix la recette du
bouillon nouvelle génération fonctionne
si bien que l'équipe cherche désormais
un lieu de l'autre côté de la Seine pour
ouvrir un troisième restaurant
François Régis vous avez consacré
d'ailleurs tout un espace dans votre
livre au bouillon c'est institution
parisienne comment vous expliquer ce
retour en grâce finalement de ces
restaurants un peu désuet quand on
regarde le décor parce que ce sont je
crois des établissements qui servent une
cuisine familiale rassurante et qui a
surtout le mérite d'être accessible dans
une époque où il y a la crise de
l'énergie toute la toutes les
problématiques que l'on connaît du
pouvoir d'achat l'inflation etc c'est
effectivement une solution de
restauration qui gagne tout simplement
parce que elle nourrit une clientèle
très large qui vient d'ailleurs aussi
bien de Paris que de province et même
les étrangers se sont donnés le mot
c'est assez drôle parce que j'ai
fréquenté j'étais à New York pour les
fêtes j'ai rencontré un de mes confrères
critiques gastronomiques de New York
Times ce qui me racontait mais alors
qu'est-ce que ça donne ce bouillon
Pigalle et il y a une curiosité on sait
New York est très porté sur Paris en
termes de restauration et d'inspiration
et ils étaient très curieux de savoir
comment fonctionnait ce bouillon
parisien
qui arrive à servir des centaines de
plats par jour tout en résolvant cette
équation compliquée de faire de la
qualité en quantité c'est bon ou pas
parce que quand on sert jusqu'à 2000
repas par jour notamment le samedi
est-ce qu'on arrive à conjuguer les deux
finalement avoir une nourriture de
qualité et alors voilà vous l'avez dit
nourriture de qualité c'est pas dans ce
lieu où vous allez gravir des sommets
d'émotions mais en tout cas vous avez le
mérite d'y aller d'être nourri encore
une fois avec un très bon rapport
qualité-prix à travers des assiettes
généreuses et une cuisine qui a le
mérite d'être faite entièrement maison
et puis je pense qu'il y a ce côté un
peu patrimonial qui résonne en nous il
faut quand même imaginer que ces
établissements ils sont pas des nulle
part ils ont tout simplement été
inventés au milieu du 19e siècle par un
certain Duval qui était bouché du côté
des Halles de Paris qui a eu l'idée
comme ça de créer des grands
établissements pour nourrir justement le
petit peuple de Paris dans une du boeuf
par exemple bouillie
était une façon de recycler les eaux les
cartes de faire au départ des bouillons
et puis ensuite évidemment l'offre
culinaire s'est étoffée et c'est comme
ça en fait que le bouillon est apparu et
c'est vraiment développé il faut quand
même imaginer qu'en 1893 il y avait
jusqu'à 400 bouillons dans Paris ensuite
la formule effectivement périté et puis
avec des brasseries qui ont un peu cassé
l'arrivée des brasseries sont devenus un
peu plus populaires elles ont fait de
l'ombre au bouillon qui ont eu tendance
à disparaître il les restait quand même
quelques quelques survivants historiques
comme le fameux bouillon Chartier rue du
Faubourg Montmartre et puis on constate
que la formule elle commence à à
reprendre du poil de la belle différence
avec une brasserie le bouillon on est
vraiment
j'ai envie de dire qu'on est dans un
bistrot à grande échelle là où la
brasserie beaucoup plus grande
en général un bouillon il y a vraiment
une échelle de de service qui est
considérable puisque c'est au minimum
400 couverts donc c'est vraiment des des
bistrots à très grande échelles on y
retrouve justement des plats de
brasserie mais également des plats de
bistrot le critère évidemment c'est
d'être pas très cher mais d'être quand
même dans une un décor assez historique
confortable
de l'Art Nouveau art déco qui fait aussi
la singularité de ces lieux exactement
même si on n'a pas tout à fait les mêmes
Arts Décoratifs que dans les grandes
brasseries parisiennes qui sont
généralement historiques on a quand même
un véritable effort qui est fait sur
un peu de trouver ces vieux décors
parisiens oui puis moi ce que j'aime en
fait je me suis attabli il y a encore
quelques semaines c'est qu'on y trouve
vraiment le couple de touristes anglais
la famille belge qui vient pour les
fêtes vous avez Chantal de la Creuse qui
vient aussi
ils mangeaient ça choucroute ou bien son
bœuf bourguignon et vous avez bien
entendu la petite tablée de Bobo
duomarais branché avec des bras tatoués
quoi et c'est ça qui est assez chouette
c'est cette espèce de mélange
typiquement parisien qui est d'ailleurs
un mélange sociologique que l'on avait
déjà dans les bistrots d'origine à la
fin du 19e vous prenez quoi quand vous
allez au bouillon vous quel est votre
plat totem ah bah là en l'occurrence
que j'aime beaucoup parce que pour le
coup mais maintenant tout le monde le
fait
que vous avez trois demi-heure pour 2
euros 70 avec une mayonnaise maison très
généreuse et particulièrement bien
assaisonnée d'ailleurs ils ont ils ont
ils en envoient quand même 1000 par jour
des des
omayos après j'ai écouté aussi la la
choucroute que je trouve vraiment très
honnête et puis vous avez le bœuf
Bourguignon coquillette qui marche bien
vous avez également des profits rôles au
chocolat alors là c'est carrément la
montagne de chou avec sa lave de
chocolat coulant qui arrive et qui coûte
pas plus de 7 euros je crois donc on est
quand même dans une expérience tout à
fait intéressante qui en plus elle
mérite de plaire beaucoup aux enfants
mais pour que ce soit rentable faut
qu'il y ait un peu débile il y en a
beaucoup est-ce que du coup on n'est pas
un peu pressé pour déjeuner est-ce que
c'est pas un peu plat sur plat et puis
en trois quarts d'heure hop alors quand
on veut s'attabler pour un petit resto
avec des amis c'est un non on a le temps
quand même de pas trop la pression c'est
vrai que ça les arrange si vous avez
expédié votre déjeuner ou votre dîner en
45 minutes mais en même temps moi j'ai
déjà vu la dernière fois que j'y suis
allé une un petit peu d'espagnol qui
était juste à côté de moi c'était au
déjeuner et je peux vous assurer qu'ils
sont restés en buvant d'ailleurs
quelques cuvées maison jusqu'à 16h30 et
on avait l'impression que bah il
dégustaient jusqu'à pas d'heure l'art de
vivre à la française Stéphanie Despierre
journaliste n'a pas pu rentrer dans les
cuisines elle le dit d'ailleurs dans le
reportage très honnêtement vous les
connaissez je suis sûr les cuisines de
séduire est-ce qu'il y a des choses à
cacher des choses mystérieuses
honnêtement je suis pas sûr qui est
grand chose à cacher parce qu'ils ont
vraiment une politique du fait maison de
A à Z et ils ont même plus que cela le
souci d'un sourcing le plus proche de
Paris par exemple les œufs qui servent à
faire le maillot ils viennent d'un d'une
ferme du Gâtinais l'Orient aussi
viennent d'élevage d'Île-de-France ils
le font non seulement parce que c'est à
la mode d'être vertueux mais ils le font
aussi pour des raisons de travail en
direct et de transport attention ce sont
des commerçants après je pense que ce
qu'ils ont plutôt à cacher c'est
l'échelle de production qui pourrait un
peu effrayer quand vous avez un bœuf
bourguignon qui est fait non pas dans
une petite cocotte en cuivre mais
généralement en fait dans une cuve de
10000 litres effectivement on se dit que
c'est pas forcément très télégénique on
casse le rêve
quand même bah c'est une espèce de
cantine améliorée mais la cantine si on
décide dès le départ de faire à grande
échelle du fait maison avec de bons
produits et des process des recettes de
cuisine ben respectueuse de la tradition
moi ça me gêne pas plus que ça d'être
dans une cantine est-ce qu'il y a des
plats un peu oubliés genre tripes de
Caen des abats les escargots ça on le
trouve fréquemment aussi et les
escargots on les trouve précisément dans
ce genre d'établissement c'est même le
lieu où on trouve des escargots
effectivement avec leur fameux beurre
persillées je crois beaucoup aussi en un
retour et pas seulement à Paris
d'ailleurs on a retour de de des
produits tripier comme vous le disiez
des abats des tripes les tripes à la
normande contrairement à leur nom ça a
été un plat qui a été inventé à Paris
justement et c'est un plat que l'on
retrouve de plus en plus c'est une très
très bonne façon finalement les les
produits tripiers de
l'intégralité des ressources que l'on
trouve sur la carcasse d'un animal quand
sacrifier un animal pour le manger la
moindre des choses et d'aller exploiter
sa carcasse dans dans les moindres
recoins et les produits trépied c'est
vraiment une façon de ne pas laisser de
côté tout ce qui est tout ce que l'on
appelle le 5e quartier et c'est la
cucina powera un peu à la française
voilà il faut pas pour être précis c'est
vrai que c'est la vache folle avait
porté un coup qu'on avait pensé fatale
au tripes les triperies avaient fermés
aujourd'hui effectivement on revoit un
retour notamment dans des villes comme
quand ou même Lyon qui aime les tripes
moi j'adore personnellement les tripes
absolument
alors les Français aiment les bouillons
et les restaurants en général mais ils
aiment encore plus donner leur avis sur
les établissements au risque de défaire
une réputation on en parle et on met les
pieds dans le plat
tu n'as pas jeté un coup d'œil sur les
avis laissé par les consommateurs avant
de réserver une table au restaurant que
valent-ils réellement ses avis sont-ils
une plaie ou au contraire une aubaine
pour les chefs c'est une enquête
d'Hélène Bonduelle et de Charlotte sebir
les casales carbonara sont pour vous et
je vous souhaite bon dégustation
pour manger c'est pas de fraîches ses
clients n'ont laissés aucune place au
hasard en fait c'est ma fille qui me l'a
proposé à ce qu'il paraît en mange ici
les meilleurs pâtes de tout Paris comme
vous savez comment je les meilleurs
pâtes de Paris je suis allée chez Google
et après j'ai recherché et les meilleurs
pâtissiers à Paris donc on est venu ici
sur le site de la fourchette et on est
venu ça doit être la troisième quatrième
fois qu'on revient parce que c'est très
bon ça permet de faire un tri on va dire
parce qu'il y en a quand même une offre
qui est assez importante de restaurant
sur Paris et que voilà donc et même
quand on part en vacances en fait vous
avez quelque part vous ne connaissez
rien c'est important de savoir par où
commencer neuf Français sur 10
consultent ses avis de clients pour
trouver la bonne adresse
pour nous permettre d'avoir un avis sur
Tripadvisor merci beaucoup
très très bon incontournable fabuleux ce
restaurant traditionnel italien est très
bien classé sur le site Tripadvisor 125
m sur plus de 15000 restaurants
parisiens un classement effectué grâce
au notes que les clients laissent sur le
site mais la responsable le sait une
mauvaise expérience peut tout changer en
quelques clics
j'ai découvert ce TripAdvisor la cliente
le client ne s'est pas manifester par
contre je me souviens très bien de la
table c'est moi même qu'il y a servi qui
a proposé les plats qu'il a servi qui a
retiré les assiettes les assiettes elle
était super bien nettoyées cet avis là
nous avait fait perdre 23 positions
c'est énorme et surtout l'impact
immédiat le soir pour le lendemain des
avis bon ou mauvais auxquels Kara
Malaguti répond systématiquement
d'ailleurs elle le reconnaît
aujourd'hui impossible pour elle de se
passer de ces sites de conseils aux
voyageurs
[Musique]
ah
les billets de ça nous met invisibilité
seront le passage je vois qu'il y a du
monde et selon la bonne idée si vous
voyez du monde dans un restaurant ça
veut dire qu'on mange bien ça vous
attire de l'autre clientèle entretenir
sa réputation sur Internet et devenu
indispensable les restaurants étoilés le
savent bien aussi les critiques des
guides gastronomiques ne suffisent plus
c'était longtemps dénigré les réseaux
sociaux tout ça les gens disaient voilà
aujourd'hui on peut pas faire ça et je
pense que s'il faut l'utiliser comme
comme outil aussi de promotion les
étoilés font très attention aux avis ils
ont un atout supplémentaire dans leur
manche je dirais puisque en termes de
service ils ont un lien un peu
privilégié avec le client et en général
il passe du temps avec eux à la fin du
service à partir de ce moment-là on peut
recueillir un avis qu'il soit positif ou
négatif mais surtout négatif avant qu'il
soit diffusé et c'est un c'est un moment
assez privilégié qu'on va pas forcément
retrouver dans d'autres types de
restauration
pour faire face aux commentaires
frauduleux malhonnête les restaurateurs
souhaiteraient que les avis clients ne
soient plus anonymes
alors vous le critiquent gastronomique
vous êtes au-dessus de ces avis où vous
les lisez avant d'entrer dans un
restaurant pour vous rassurer un petit
peu
on peut pas les négliger et on est
obligé de faire avec on assiste à
l'avènement de ce qu'on pourra appeler
une démocratie gastronomique quoi
désormais le jugement gastronomique ce
n'est plus seulement la panache de
quelques professionnels et de quelques
guides vous évoquez tout à l'heure
Jean-Pierre le Michelin aujourd'hui tout
un chacun peut s'improviser du jour au
lendemain critique gastronomique et
distribué un peu comme ça lui chante ses
avis à temps et à travers sur les
comètes de bougies
parce que vous vous mettez le doigt sur
la problématique c'est que quelle est la
légitimité de leur avis moi je considère
quand même que tout le monde a un avis
sur sur le problème alors est-ce qu'il
est bon en fait cette problématique là
concerne finalement nos réseaux sociaux
de manière plus générale c'est-à-dire
qu'aujourd'hui on constate quand même
que ces sites pour remettre un avis sur
un restaurant ou un commerce de bouche
qu'on a visité c'est globalement le
grand défouloir où on rivalisent d'avis
les plus tordu les uns que les autres ça
veut pas dire que pour autant c'est pas
un outil qui peut servir à des
restaurateurs il y a des restaurateurs
qui sont très content de l'existence de
TripAdvisor vous diriez que c'est fiable
ou pas alors
en fait pour une peau pour une partie je
pense que ça a permis de renforcer une
vraie transparence et ça a permis aussi
d'ailleurs de mettre en avant certaines
petites pratiques un peu douteuses ou
frauduleuses de certains restaurateurs
voilà sur les prix sur le service sur
par exemple l'origine de certains
produits servis dans l'assiette et
certains clients s'en étonnent etc à
bons droit donc ça permet évidemment de
rendre les restaurateurs peut-être plus
vigilants et en même temps
c'est assez dévastateur pour d'autres
j'ai envie de dire que c'est un peu 55
ans en fait c'est à dire que ça rend
service y compris à moi-même d'ailleurs
qu'on cherche une adresse très souvent
j'ai le réflexe désormais d'aller voir
ce qu'on pense un site comme TripAdvisor
ça ne me donne pas du tout un avis
absolu ça permet de compléter
éventuellement un comment dire de
compléter une idée à priori que je peux
me faire du restaurant
à tort une réputation et c'est le
problème c'est à dire que le problème de
ces avis sur Internet c'est que c'est
c'est qu'on en a pas tellement
appréhendé les limites vous évoquez à la
fin du sujet cette solution qui me
semble être la bonne et d'ailleurs j'en
ai parlé avec plusieurs chefs dans le
milieu il y a des initiatives qui qui
vont qui vont très certainement voir le
jour c'est l'idée désormais de se battre
pour contre l'anonymat c'est aussi
valable sur Twitter dans d'autres sujets
c'est valable sur tous les réseaux
sociaux
je crois que ce serait une solution qui
permettrait en tout cas de
responsabiliser les avis qui sont postés
lorsque l'on se cache pas derrière un
troll ou un anonymat effectivement on
fait plus attention à ce que l'on écrit
et on passait beau vous avez déjà été
enchantés par un restaurant mal noté et
déçu par un très bien noté oui
évidemment mais il y a quand même un
écart tout à fait important entre ce que
peut dire d'un restaurant TripAdvisor et
ce que peut en dire j'ai envie de dire
des des outils un peu officiels comme le
guide Michelin Go Emilio le Fooding et
d'autres sites et moi même d'ailleurs
puisque moi-même je participe évidemment
à cet avis général à de mon émission
très très bon mais il y a des écarts
très très souvent parce que vous vous
rendez compte que la note d'un reste de
la note de Tripadvisor la note globale
elle a pas vraiment les mêmes critères
que celui d'un d'un guide gastronomique
Le guide gastronomique va beaucoup
s'attacher à l'origine des produits
alors qualité à la juste cuisson à
l'équilibre de l'assaisonnement là où
sur Tripadvisor on va d'abord
s'intéresser au prix quel que soit en
fait la qualité c'est à dire que quand
souvent sur Tripadvisor je vois mais
c'est horriblement cher bah oui mais on
se rend compte en fait que le client
quand il a posté la photo il a une très
belle somme mais vous faites la
différence entre une seule du Sénégal
qui coûte un tiers d'une sole de ligne
qui est pêché à Noirmoutier ou à au
Guilvinec et là on a pas à faire au même
produit donc il faut évidemment aussi
tenir compte il y a un peu de démagogie
c'est ça que je veux dire aussi et de
méconnaissance de la part de ces
jugements qui sont balancés comme ça
peut explosif vous savez balancer à
chaud lorsqu'on est journaliste
gastronomique en général on trempe on
tourne cette fois ça plume dans
l'encrier avant de porter un jugement là
où en général on se rend compte que les
avis sur Tripadvisor ils sont postés sur
le palier du restaurant quand on sort et
qu'on a payé l'addition parfois
un peu excédé pour des raisons alors
peut-être qu'il y a parfois un fond de
vérité mais en général c'est souvent un
miroir grossissant qui rend pas vraiment
en service au lieu de lever l'anonymat
sur les réseaux sociaux est-ce qu'il
faudrait pas plutôt professionneliser la
notation que ce soit un petit peu plus
compliqué de mettre un avis qui est des
critères à remplir parce que là les gens
ils mettent deux trois phrases en
sortant c'est assez rapide s'il y avait
je sais pas des questions un peu plus
compliquées alors on pouvait imaginer
des garde-fous mais après c'est très
compliqué d'évaluer la légitimité la
crédibilité de quelqu'un qui veut poster
un avis c'est à dire que si il faut lui
faire passer
de cette manière là simplement j'ai
tendance à penser que un client qui veut
dire du bien ou du mal d'un restaurant
quel que soit le process il arrivera
toujours à ses fins s'il a vraiment
envie de porter un avis soit pour rendre
service au restaurateurs ou soit pour
faire la Loire son son aigreur ou sa ou
sa rancune ce qui est sûr c'est que les
consommateurs ont pris le pouvoir on le
voit bien on se reportage et certains
resteront à toi quand ses amis sont
arrivés ils étaient fous furieux et
aujourd'hui ils sont pris au piège on
voit bien la restauratrice dans le sujet
elle dit regardez le QR code donnez
votre avis elles attendent maintenant
les avis avant il les redoutait
effectivement c'est difficile de sortir
de cette spirale là maintenant c'est une
contrainte de plus qui tombe sur qui te
donne des épaules du restaurateur il y a
déjà évidemment le prix de l'énergie
c'est en plein dans l'actualité il y
avait effectivement la sanction le coup
près de ces institutions officielles que
sont les guides qui existent dans la
visite des critiques gastronomiques et
désormais vous avez cette démocratie
gastronomique qui peut virer
malheureusement à la dictature si on
prend pas garde à ses dérives qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire un restaurateur face à
ces critiques
ce qu'il faut répondre est-ce qu'il faut
réagir
la seule façon peut-être de contrer un
avis
un avis négatif c'est peut-être bien
d'essayer de comprendre des explications
les restaurateurs quand ils s'en sortent
le mur c'est quand il se met dans la
position de celui qui comprend que le
client est roi quel que soit ce qu'il
dit quel que soit les excès de son
propos il faut essayer de toujours
comprendre ce qu'il pense hier j'avais
un rendez-vous avec Cyril Lignac voilà
un restaurateur qui est sur la 7
gastronomique à Paris à travers une
douzaine de enfin non peut-être pas huit
ou neuf restaurants il me disait je
tombe parfois sur les clients les plus
entre guillemets chiants j'ai toujours
quelque chose à tirer de leur critique
je les écoute toujours et c'est vrai que
le restaurateur doit quand même
se souvenir que c'est que le client paye
quoi et puis ça nous c'est une remarque
mais ça nous éclaire aussi sur la vie
précédente parce que ça permet de le
modérer et c'est intéressant si la
réponse
justifier le manquement l'erreur et puis
ça permet aussi d'atténuer effectivement
le le l'impact ou l'influence d'un d'un
avis positif ou négatif allez on passe
au dessert à présent et c'est le péché
mignon
alors Brigitte volume le temps du sucré
avec un Paris-Brest quelle barbe se
Paris Brest on en mange tous les jours
et toutes les semaines avec Brigitte
j'allais dire encore un c'est dingue
comme ce gâteau est plébiscité par nos
invités quelle que soit leur bord
politique leurs origines etc vous lui
accordez deux pages entière dans votre
livre et vous relatez la petite histoire
de ce célèbre gâteau mariage de la pâte
à chou et de la crème pralinée la
pâtisserie Durand à Maisons-Laffitte
revendique sa paternité une douceur en
forme de roue de vélo créée en 2010 par
en 1910 pardon par Louis Durand en
hommage à la course cycliste Paris-Brest
c'est votre passion pour Poulidor qui
vous a fait aimer ce gâteau et ce régime
c'est vrai que j'aime bien la petite
reine je vais pas vous les cacher
Jean-Pierre les caresses la petite reine
je préfère on va dire le Paris-Brest
dans mon assiette que sur la route que
sur Youtube
en tous les cas c'est un gâteau que
j'aime beaucoup bah moi je suis pas du
tout parisien je ne le suis pas de
naissance je suis plutôt Corse par ma
mère et Lyonnais par mon père mais ce
qui est assez curieux pour montrer à
quel point d'ailleurs Paris a eu un
impact colossal notamment dans le
répertoire sucré dans la France entière
et dans le monde c'est que le Paris
Ouest en fait voilà peut-être qu'il
était destiné à voyager avec sa forme de
roue de vélo mais il a voyagé dans la
France entière et assez curieusement je
mangeais très régulièrement des
paris-brestres pour nos déjeuner
Dominico à Lyon où je suis resté jusqu'à
l'âge de 19 ans et quand je suis arrivé
pour mes études à Paris vers 20 ans plus
de Paris Brest dans les vitrines c'était
un gâteau considéré comme un gars
mais il a changé maintenant parce que là
on le trouve en forme de roue de vélo
mais maintenant il est décliné sous
d'autres formes comme un éclair ou alors
ça c'est
un peu pareil j'ai une course cycliste
et être carré parce que les roulé avec
des roues carrées c'est pas facile en ce
qui compte c'est d'avoir effectivement
le côté Patachou d'avoir ses amants
défilé sur le dessus moi je suis
vraiment fan parce que j'adore la
noisette je suis un véritable écureuil
depuis le début et ce qu'il faut quand
même préciser c'est que il y a un chef
pâtissier à qui on doit beaucoup le
retour du Paradise on était dans les
années 2005 2006 c'est Philippe
Conticini ce grand chef pâtissier qui a
eu l'idée de remettre au goût du jour un
certain nombre de traditions pâtissière
qui était considéré jusqu'à lors comme
un port ringarde ou c'est dans les
années 90 pierre armé le même Philippe
Conticini avait tourné la partie vers
quelque chose de très cérébral de très
intellectuel avec des gâteaux design
très innovants des mariages de saveurs
très créatifs et là on revient
effectivement une fois fondamentaux
aussi un peu plus de simplicité
peut-être dans le dessert alors
simplicité pour faire vous savez la
simplicité c'est ce qui est plus
compliqué en cuisine mais cette
simplicité c'est effectivement l'idée
qu'on a un gâteau avec uniquement de
saveurs de la pâte à choux une crème
pralinée et on s'y retrouve vous le
faites vous-même non là pour le coup
je suis pas du tout dans les défis
pâtissiers je suis pas très alors je
fais des desserts mais je vais faire on
va dire des gâteaux de ménage entre
guillemets quoi c'est à dire un très bon
gâteau au chocolat ou je fais un cake au
citron qui a beaucoup de succès par
exemple mais je me lance pas vraiment
dans des prouesses techniques c'est
compliqué que ça des défis pâtissiers
c'est vrai mais après je suis pas aussi
à l'aise que vous avec une poche à
douille
le meilleur Paris-Brest de Paris est-ce
que vous les avez tous goûtés ou pas
alors là c'est chez Françoise c'est chez
Françoise à côté des Invalides
parce que j'ai vu que la maison à
Maisons-Laffitte du Val en fait toujours
est-ce que elle a gardé son
honnêtement il est même super bon
c'était Louis Durand comme vous l'avez
dit qu'il a inventé l'adresse appartient
à la même famille ils font exactement la
même recette qui ressemble un peu
celle-là d'ailleurs et c'est un dessert
tout à fait classique pour en revenir au
très bon paris-rest il y a évidemment
celui de Philippe conticiné que j'aime
beaucoup parce qu'il a une intelligence
pâtissier
de mettre une petite inclusion de
praliné coulant à l'intérieur de la de
la crème de la crème au praliné et
lorsque vous coupez votre Paribas vous
avez une espèce de sensation volcanique
d'un petit orange de praliné qui coule
dans votre assiette et c'est vraiment
délicieux
évidemment pour une nouvelle émission de